erst hätte eine kleine hat lockdown rede
dann zieht armin laschet im flugzeug
lang nur 60 minuten vorher appellierte
nrw-ministerpräsident noch masken zu
tragen und abstand zu halten
die lage ist sehr sehr ernst und auch
bei friedrich merz scheiterte flugzeug
die maske etwas lockerer zu sitzen als
vor den fernsehkameras auch bei anne
will im ersten spricht armin laschet
mahnende und warnende corona worte
ein notstand stunde uns bevor wenn wir
nicht gemeinsam die regeln akzeptieren
und beachten würden
doch kaum läuft der abspann der sendung
sieht man nichts mehr von abstand halten
und maske tragen keine guten szenen die
wir dort von friedrich merz und armin
laschet sehen und genau darüber möchte
ich jetzt sprechen mit meinem kollegen
haben es ja auch viele wald bei mir im
studio
jeder sollte eine maske tragen das
erzählen wir sogar kindern jetzt und
ausgerechnet die wichtigsten politiker
die wir hier im land haben lassen sich
so fotografieren wenn auch nicht ganz
bewusst ohne maske wie bitter ist das ja
das ist natürlich aus der abteilung ups
erwischt
man kann davon ausgehen dass die auch
diese politiker wann immer sie sich
beobachtet fühlen und wahrscheinlich
auch im rest der zeit normalerweise ihre
masken ordentlich tragen manchmal nicht
ganz bewusst dass das eben eine
dauerbeobachtung es tatsächlich und bei
armin laschet war es einfach so er hatte
diesem tag hinter sich gebracht im bund
länder gipfel dann eine wichtige rede
noch einmal an sein nordrhein
westfälisches volk und hat dort eben
noch mal darauf hingewiesen denkt daran
es ist ein notstand wir müssen uns alle
an diese regeln halten gemeinsinn ist
gefragt wir alle wie alle steigt in den
flieger und lässt dann maske herunter
hängen um sich mit seinem pressesprecher
zu besprechen
das sei es dabei wenn sie beobachtet
sind dann sagen sie einem fall darum
soll es ja bei masken nicht gehen nur
weil ich beobachtet werde trage ich sie
das heißt eigentlich schon sagen das ist
bei den politikern auch noch nicht ganz
angekommen wie wichtig aber er sagt
angekommen hat sich einfach in dem
moment unbeobachtet gefühlt und wusste
nicht dass man ausgerechnet ein jahr in
dem fall dann späterer bezeuge
da ein foto von macht musst du wohl auch
nicht dass das dokumentiert ist und der
wird zeuge sagt auch das war überwiegend
auf diesem flug so hat selten die maske
getragen
angeblich so sagt der sprecher hätte
sich was hätte ich etwas gegessen
zwischendurch da sagt er
sagen sie es gab gar nichts zu essen da
etwas gesehen kein solches amt essen
bekommen dann sagt aber wieder die
umgebung von laschet nein ihr habt es
dann doch noch zur stewardess hat sich
einen snack geholt und für diesen zweck
hat er dann die maske abgenommen
jetzt ist aber trotzdem natürlich vor
allem die frage was für auswirkungen hat
das auf die glaubhaftigkeit denn sowieso
jetzt wieder corona krise fällt es immer
schwerer
bei manchen dingen als bürger noch zu
wissen warum wir das alles machen müssen
aber immer wieder wird dazu aufgerufen
wie ernst es ist die politik sagt wir
müssen jetzt alle an einem strang ziehen
was machen solche bilder dann mit all
den reden die armin laschet dann hält
das für ärger natürlich diejenigen die
sich jeden tag mit ihrer maske in den
supermarkt jeden tag in der mit der
maske im büro womöglich an
krankenhäusern aufhalten und denen das
masken tragen welche auch auf die nerven
geht die aber sagen na gut der gewinn
der gemeinsinn denn will
auch wenn sich politiker dann ich sage
mal die blöße geben auf diese weise zu
zeigen naja sie halten sich auch nicht
durchgehend dran dann ist dann zerstört
das einfach vertrauen in politik in
diejenigen die uns diese regeln
auferlegt haben möglicherweise auch aus
guten gründen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren